[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal live aus
Kiew mit Marietta Slomka
guten Abend in der Hauptstadt der
Ukraine ist es jetzt am Abend sehr still
es sind kaum noch Autos oder Menschen
auf der Straßen es ist so still dass man
quer durch die Stadt manchmal sogar
Hundebellen hört als wenn man irgendwo
auf dem Land und nicht in einer
Millionenmetropole es ist am Ende dieses
Jahres Tages also ein stilles Gedenken
an das was hier vor einem Jahr begonnen
hat wobei die Ukraine ja meist nicht vom
Kriegsbeginn sprechen der Krieg hat für
sie schon 2014 bekommen sie nennen es
den Beginn der vollumfänglichen Invasion
von Osten Norden Süden fehlen die
russischen Truppen ein Kiew sollte im
Sturm erobert werden daraus wurde
bekanntlich nichts
Video Ukraine und die Welt dieser
Ereignisse heute gedachten berichtet
Christiane Hoffmann
innehalten zusammenstehen wie hier in
Burscheid gedenken die Ukraine überall
ihre Toten Söhne und Töchter ein Jahr
haben sie der Invasion Russlands Stand
gehalten der Preis unermesslich
es war ein sehr schwieriges Jahr ich
habe meinen Mann verloren ich hoffe dass
bald Frieden sein wird dieser Horror
muss enden
nie werden Sie diesen Tag vergessen als
Hubschrauber und Panzer kamen als alles
anders wurde in Botschaft für einige
Wochen doch mit hunderten Toten im Osten
der Ukraine bis heute
Schweigen für die Opfer im Herzen von
Kiew Präsident selenski ehrt die Truppe
und die gefallenen Soldaten das
ukrainische Volk habe nicht die weiße
Fahne gehisst sagte er sondern
Widerstand geleistet das werde zum
Erfolg führen 2023 das Jahr des Sieges
werden
ich danke allen die diesen Februar und
dieses Jahr durchgehalten haben und die
die Ukraine unbeugsam machen
der Blick richtet sich heute auch nach
vorn Polens Ministerpräsident
moraviewski bringt die ersten vier
Leopard 2 Panzer nach Kiew mit macht das
enge Bündnis mit dem Nachbarn deutlich
Deutschland hat heute vier Panzer mehr
als bisher für die Ukraine versprochen
bei der Gedenkfeier im Schloss Bellevue
in Berlin ist auch Präsident selenski
zugeschaltet und dank für die Hilfe
Bundespräsident steinmeier sagte die
deutschen bewunderten den Mut der
Ukraine und teilten ihre Trauer und bei
allen Kontroversen und manchmal
schrillen Debatten bin ich sicher wir
werden das auch weiterhin sein deshalb
sage ich auch mit Blick auf das was noch
vor uns liegt auf Deutschland ist
Verlass die mädchener
hat heute einen 12 Punkte Plan für
Frieden veröffentlicht fordert zu
Gesprächen auf und dazu die Souveränität
von Staaten zu respektieren Russlands
Krieg verurteilt hat China aber bisher
nicht die EU skeptisch
wir werden ihn anschauen aber vor dem
Hintergrund dass China sich auf die
Seite von Russland gestellt hat für
Frieden und gegen emperialismus rund um
die Welt setzen die Menschen heute
Zeichen in blau-gelb von Sydney über
Brüssel bis Paris
und auch bei Russlands Nachbarn Georgien
gingen Tausende für die Ukraine auf die
Straße denn auch sie fürchten um ihre
Unabhängigkeit
wenn man sich durch Kiew bewegt kann man
auf den ersten Blick den Eindruck haben
in einer normalen Metropole zu sein doch
dann springt einem all das ins Auge was
nicht normal ist die vielen Soldaten im
Stadtbild auch im Cafés oder Kneipen die
Panzersperren auf den Straßen die
Checkpoints an denen man kontrolliert
wird und die man nicht filmen oder
fotografieren darf da stehen dann
Verschläge von Tarnnetzen umhüllt davor
Soldaten oft noch ein Ölfass in dem
Feuer brennt damit sie sich etwas wärmen
können die zeitenwände von der Olaf
Scholz sprach ist hier ganz unmittelbar
zu spüren was sie für Deutschland
bedeutet beleuchtet jetzt Andrea Maurer
und sie beginnt damit wie vor einem Jahr
in Berlin die Nachricht vom russischen
Angriff einschlug
es ist der 24 Februar 4:30 Uhr als der
Kanzler und seinen Berater starb von
einer SMS aus dem Lagezentrum geweckt
werden Putin hat die Ukraine angegriffen
glaube es war eine Mischung aus ein
Gefühl dass ich etwas einstellt was man
schon länger befürchtet hatte und
trotzdem der Ernst der Situation ich
erinnere mich sehr an die Blicke
in dem Sicherheitskabinett die sich die
Kabinettsmitglieder zugeworfen haben nur
neun Tage zuvor am 15 Februar war Scholz
noch bei Putin im Kanzleramt haben sie
danach immer öfter das Undenkbare für
möglich gehalten und wollten es doch
nicht richtig glauben
der Bundeskanzler hat ihn an einer
Stelle gefragt kann es mir passieren
wenn ich in mein Flugzeug steige und
zurück nach Deutschland fliege dass ich
quasi die aufsteigenden Kampfjets von
ihnen sehe und diese Frage hat Putin
nicht beantwortet und das war etwas was
aus diesem Treffen mit nach Deutschland
sozusagen genommen wurde gleichzeitig
war es aber auch so dass es auch noch
eine Rest Hoffnung gegeben hat das ist
nicht zu diesem Konflikt kommen würde in
den ersten Tagen nach Kriegsausbruch
geht die Regierung noch von einem
schnellen sie großlands aus 48 Stunden
sagt der Geheimdienst der ukrainische
Botschafter melik bittet um Termine mit
politisch Handelnden viele Türen bleiben
verschlossen der Finanzminister empfängt
ihn das war quasi das Gefühl der
Verzweiflung mit dem ich alle Minister
angeschrieben oder halt Besuch habe wie
wie ein Linda und natürlich hat mich das
umgehauen weil er schien das kann nicht
aus meiner Sicht erkannt zu haben worum
es ging ja dass das wirklich ein ein
enormer ein großer Krieg ist dass
Menschen sterben und das zumindest ab
dem Moment der Handlungsbedarf akut
gewesen wäre der Handlungsdruck auf die
Regierung wächst während die
Verteidigungsministerin noch am Tag des
Kriegsausbruchs das Nein zu
Waffenlieferungen bekräftigt beginnt am
25 Februar im Kanzleramt erstmals ein
Umdenken
in diesem Land gibt es eine Tradition
dass wir keine Waffen in Kriegs oder
Krisengebieten in größerem Umfang
liefern so war das über Jahrzehnte und
das stand ich würde sagen ab Freitag
stark in Frage und an dem Samstag im
Laufe des Tages war dann die
Entscheidung ja man bricht mit diesem
Tabu man geht diesen Schritt weil alles
andere nicht verantwortbar wäre
am 26 Februar genehmigt der Kanzler
erstmals Waffenlieferungen an die
Ukraine und die Regierung wird mitmachen
beim Ausschluss von Russland aus dem
Zahlungssystem Swift als Kanzleramtschef
Wolfgang Schmidt um 23 Uhr das
Kanzleramt verlässt twittert er wurde
day was für ein Tag
und dann beginnt der 27 Februar nur
wenige sind eingeweiht das Olaf Scholz
an diesem Tag Deutschlands politischen
Kurs korrigieren wird neue
Energiepolitik neue Außenpolitik massive
Aufrüstung eine Art neuer
Koalitionsvertrag um 11 Uhr 25 kommt er
zum wichtigsten Punkt seiner Rede ein
Sondervermögen dass er mit dem
Finanzminister vereinbart hat der
Bundeshaushalt 2022 wird dieses
Sondervermögen einmalig mit 100
Milliarden Euro ausstatten die Mittel
werden wir für notwendige Investitionen
und Rüstungsvorhaben nutzen es ist ein
wuchtiges versprechen im Angesicht des
russischen Angriffskrieges an dem sich
der Kanzler und seine Regierung von nun
an messen lassen müssen
wie sehr dieser Krieg die Welt verändert
hat und wir weitergehen kann darüber
habe ich am Abend mit der
bundesaußenministerin gesprochen mit
Annalena baerbock
und die bundesaußenministerin ist uns
aus New York jetzt zugeschaltet guten
Abend Frau bärbock
schönen guten Abend bzw schönen guten
Tag von hier
sie haben ja heute vom UNO
Sicherheitsrat gesprochen das ist
natürlich das Gremium das einzige das
wirklich Macht entfalten kann bei den
Vereinten Nationen aber das ist ja
eigentlich auch vergebliche Mühe denn
Russland wird das Blockieren und China
würde auch keine gemeinsame Resolution
annehmen was was bringt einem also der
Sicherheitsrat dann noch in dieser Lage
indem man sichtbar macht wer in der Welt
für Frieden einsteht und wer eben das
blockiert genauso wie sie es gesagt
haben weil gestern haben in der
Generalversammlung wo ja alle Staaten
der Welt zu kommen
141 Nationen deutlich gemacht sie wollen
Frieden sie arbeiten jeden Tag wie wir
für Frieden und heute im Sicherheitsrat
habe ich daher eindringlich appelliert
an die chinesischen Vertreter dass sie
eine Verantwortung haben als Mitglied
des Sicherheitsrates man hat ja nicht
nur ein Recht ein Vetorecht alles zu
blockieren sondern es ist eigentlich die
Aufgabe des Sicherheitsrats für
Weltfrieden zu sorgen und wenn der jetzt
blockiert ist dann ist es umso wichtiger
dass die Weltgemeinschaft alle anderen
Staaten der Welt eben diesen
Friedensplan jetzt vorgelegt haben
die Chinesen haben auch einen
sogenannten Friedensplan vorgestellt der
stößt aber im Westen und auch hier in
der Ukraine auf großes Skepsis oder
ja es heißt ja auch Positionspapier weil
es fast die Position von der
chinesischen Seite aus dem letzten Jahr
zusammen gut ist dass sie noch mal
unterstreichen dass es zu keiner
nuklearen Eskalation kommen darf das ist
sehr sehr wichtig und zugleich macht
dieser Positionspapier aber auch
deutlich was man auslässt ist benennt
eben nicht den Angreifer den Aggressor
Russland es sagt nicht dass natürlich
die Ukraine gemäß der unkrater ein Recht
auf Selbstverteidigung hat es benennt
noch nicht mal diese furchtbaren
Kriegsverbrechen dieses Morden diese
Sterben von tausenden von Angriffen auf
Schulen auf Krankenhäuser und deswegen
habe ich heute hier deutlich gemacht es
gibt einen Friedensplan das ist der den
wir gestern gemeinsam mit 140 Staaten
verabschiedet haben der deutlich macht
dass Bomben muss aufhören die Soldaten
von russischer Seite müssen
zurückgezogen werden russland hat sich
vor einem Jahr entschieden die
Friedensordnung Europa zu verlassen hat
diesen brutalen Krieg angefangen und es
kann sich jeden Tag neu beiden wieder
für Frieden und dafür werben wir weiter
jeden Tag und jede Nacht
das sieht es natürlich im Moment
überhaupt nicht aus dass das Russland
sich irgendwie zurückziehen würde und
heißt es immer wir unterstützen die
Ukraine es long asset takes wie zum
Beispiel Herr beiden sagt oder so lange
wie möglich das sagt auch der
Bundeskanzler aber für die Ukraine ist
die Vorstellung dass dieser Krieg noch
ewig lang so weitergeht der eigentlich
größte Horror denn die Zeit läuft für
eher für Putin und nicht für Kiew
ja die Welt ist vor einem Jahr in einer
anderen Welt aufgewacht und die
Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer sind in einem
Albtraum aufgewacht menschen die vorher
im Kindergarten gearbeitet haben in der
Bank mussten von einem Tag auf dem
anderen alles nehmen was sie hatten sich
und ihre Kinder in Sicherheit zu bringen
oder sich im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes
selber zu verteidigen um ihr Leben zu
retten aber die internationale Hilfe die
Sanktionen aber eben auch die
Waffenlieferungen und erst recht die
humanitäre Hilfe die vielen Generatoren
in den Städten oder Stromsystem zerstört
worden ist die haben eben geholfen
weitere Leben zu retten denn das habe
ich gerade auch im Sicherheitsrat die
Chinesen und andere gefragt was wäre
denn gewesen wenn wir einfach unsere
Augen zugemacht hätten dann hätte es
noch mehr Botschaften noch mehr Mario
Puls noch mehr Vergewaltigung noch mehr
Verschleppung von Kindern gegeben das
heißt wir konnten im letzten Jahr durch
unsere intensiven diplomatischen
Bemühungen durch die Unterstützung des
Internationalen Roten Kreuzes konnten
wir weitere schlimme geheult haben sich
verhindern aber ja wir werden weiter an
der Seite der Ukraine stehen bis sie
endlich auch wieder im kompletten Land
in Frieden und in Freiheit leben kann
das ist das Ziel der Ukraine die Grenzen
von 1991 dafür müssten sie aber das hört
man auch wenn man mit den entsprechenden
Regierungsvertretern hier spricht einen
anderen Krieg führen also auch ein sehr
viel offensiveren mit noch ganz anderen
Waffen und auch auf russischen
territoriumstellungen zerstören aber
dafür läuft genau die Linie des Westens
also Wilder Westen überhaupt das
tatsächlich Russland eine richtige
empfindliche Niederlage erleidet
wir wollen dass die Ukraine gewinnt dass
die Ukraine endlich wieder in Frieden
lebt und Russland das anerkennt was
unsere Friedensordnung international
ausmacht nämlich dass jedes Land ein
Recht hat frei in seinem eigenen Land zu
leben dass jedes Land seine territoriale
Integrität so wie es heißt schützt und
dabei unterstützen wir die Ukraine dafür
werden wir alles tun und dann muss ich
auch daran erinnern die Ukraine hat ja
in den 90er Jahren freiwillig ihre
Atomwaffen abgegeben weil sie an Frieden
geglaubt haben und was wäre es jetzt für
ein Zeichen wenn ein Angriff war ein
Land das ein Angriffskrieg führt gegen
ein anderes Land was freiwillig
Atomwaffen abgegeben hat was diese wenn
dieses Land jetzt gewinnen würde das
wäre eben nicht nur das Ende der Ukraine
es wäre auch das Ende der
internationalen Ordnung wie wir sie
jetzt haben und wir wollen unsere
internationale Friedensordnung
verteidigen und das Gute ist dass sie
aller große Mehrheit der Staaten dieser
Welt das genauso sieht weil sie spürt
ein Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine oder
überall anders auf der Welt hat eben für
alle auf der Welt unglaubliche Folgen
wie zum Beispiel diese furchtbare
Ernährungskrise die sich durch den
russischen Angriffskrieg noch so viel
weiter verschärft hat
Frau bärburg danke für das Gespräch
danke ebenso
zu den Grausamkeiten dieses Krieges
gehört dass auch jeden Tag kindersterben
und zigtausende Kinder ein Elternteil
oder sogar beide Eltern verloren haben
hinzu kommt der Vorwurf das in den von
Russland besetzten Gebieten Kinder
regelrecht gekidnappt und nach Russland
verschleppt werden Putins Leute führen
sie im russischen Fernsehen vor als
dankbare befreite die nun echte Russen
werden dürfen doch auch ukrainische
Kinder die solche Schicksale nicht
erlitten haben die ihr zu Hause und ihre
Eltern noch haben die hier in Kiew auch
vergleichsweise sicher sind auch diese
Kinder sind nicht mehr die die sie vor
dem Krieg waren das habe ich in jedem
Moment gespürt den ich hier in Kiew mit
einer jungen Mutter und ihrem
achtjährigen Sohn verbracht habe
7 Uhr morgens in Kiew eine müde Mutter
macht Frühstück für ihr müdes Kind das
nicht aus dem Bett kommt seit einem Jahr
ist Katharina yakinenko alleinerziehend
ihr Mann wladislav ist an der Front er
hatte sich zu Kriegsbeginn freiwillig
gemeldet
und wo ist der jetzt gerade
in bachmut seit 40 Tagen ja es ist sehr
hart dort anfangs wollte ich ihn gar
nicht ziehen lassen ich war richtig böse
er ist schließlich mein Mann ich liebe
die Ukraine aber ich liebe auch meinen
Mann
sie sind junge Eltern lernten sich im
Studium kennen wladislav baute eine
florierende Investmentfirma auf
finanziell geht es ihnen noch sehr gut
ihr Sohn Atem geht auf eine der besten
Privatschulen Kiews und geht er da gerne
hin
muss ich wohl zu teuer wie die ist
Katharina stammt von der Krippe ihre
Mutter und Großmutter Leben noch dort es
breche ihr jedes Mal das Herz wenn sie
mit ihnen telefoniert
ich kann nicht glauben dass wenn ich
nach Hause auf die Krim fahren will dass
da an der Grenze irgendein Russe sitzt
und ich nicht einfach in mein Haus kann
sie Weine zu oft sagt Katharina der
kleine Sohn müsste da einiges auffangen
er versuche sie zu trösten und den Mann
im Haus zu ersetzen ich frage artem ob
er einen Trick habe um sich zu beruhigen
wenn er Angst oder Stress hat ja dann
hole er sich immer seinen Butterfly
Messer es ist nur aus Plastik aber ich
mag das Geräusch es bräucht mich
früher erzählt Katharina habe sie die
Russen bewundert das sei so gewesen auf
der Krim Russland der große Bruder sie
und ihr Mann waren russisch sprachig
doch im letzten Sommer haben sie sich
umgestellt beide wollen nur noch
Ukrainisch sprechen auch mit dem Kind
weil mich alles russische inzwischen nur
noch anwidert
Schule heißt Republica Kids sie legt
besonderen Wert auf Fremdsprachen vor
allem Englisch
den Kindern hier wird beste Betreuung
und Ausstattung geboten eine wahre
bilderbuchschule
doch all das kann nicht darüber hinweg
trösten was dieser Krieg einer ganzen
Generation wegnimmt Sicherheit und
Normalität einfach Kind sein
na so wie früher vor dem Krieg alles war
heller wir spielten draußen jetzt ist
alles grau und keine Kinder mehr draußen
regelmäßig wird der Ernstfall geprobt
Luftalarm jedes Kind muss die Laufwege
im Schlaf kennen
wie oft sie mit den Kindern tatsächlich
in den Bunker müssen frage ich die
Schuldirektoren
leider ziemlich oft und bei echten
Luftalarm haben wir nur fünf Minuten und
mit allen Kindern hier runter zu kommen
letzten Freitag gab es sehr starken
Beschuss da waren wir fast den ganzen
Tag hier Unterricht Verpflegung alles
wurde hier unten organisiert
mit Vogelgezwitscher und Waldbildern
versuchen Sie es den Kindern leichter zu
machen sie sollen erstmal entspannen
wenn sie in Bunker angekommen sind sich
beruhigen während draußen Raketen
fliegen
und irgendwie sollen sie auch fröhlich
bleiben
nicht nur an dieser Schule versuchen sie
wirklich alles um die Seelen ihrer
Kinder zu beschützen damit diese
Generation eine Zukunft hat
Katharinas Mann Wladimir kämpft derzeit
ja in bachmut alle hier sprechen von der
Hölle von bachmut ein unfassbares
archaischesgemetzel Russland setzt auf
die schiere Masse an Infanterie die
gegen die ukrainischen Stellungen an
rennt zu Tausenden werden sie in den
sicheren Tod geschickt das heißt dass
die Russen an den diversen Fronten
täglich zwischen 500 und 1000 Soldaten
verlieren ein autoritäres Land mit rund
140 Millionen Menschen kann sich solchen
zynisches Kalkül offenbar leisten die
Ukraine jedoch nicht und in der Front
statt bachmut leben immer noch
Zivilisten daran hat den ukrainischen
Filmemacher Oleg thumien getroffen der
in bachmut war und erzählt was er dort
erlebt
bevor vor dem Krieg haben wir Werbefilme
getreten Musikvideos und Filme
damit war es vorbei als wir uns bachmut
annäherten
man hört den Dauerbeschuss die Geräusche
der
bombenitäre Zentren sie verteilen
Lebensmittel Strom und andere Hilfsgüter
aber auch dort gibt es keine Sicherheit
wenn man die Zentren verlässt dann bist
du im Krieg Granaten schlagen ein und
wenn du dann wieder zurückkehrst dann
siehst du die Kinder die an der
Playstation Krieg spielen es ist seltsam
okay
gibt es für alle genug zu essen wenn du
ankommst das erste was einheimische dir
anbieten ist eine Mahlzeit Kartoffeln
Fleisch alles was sie haben
wir waren überrascht wie sehr sich die
Menschen daran gewöhnt haben es ist die
Alltag geworden
kein Gebäude das nicht zerstört ist
als Vater verstehe ich nicht wie man
seine Kinder einer solchen Gefahr
aussetzen kann
ich vermute sie ertragen die Gefahr hier
besser als die Ungewissheit an einem
fremden Ort
Menschen sich an alles gewöhnen können
selbst wenn es so bedrohlich ist wie
hier in bachmut
der Kids eben die Kinder zucken nicht
mehr zusammen beim lärmen des Krieges
your leise keines unserer Bilder konnte
es einfangen
konnte erklären wie es sich anfühlt hier
zu sein
kein Bild reicht aus
unglücklicherweise muss man hier sein um
zu verstehen welche Hölle es ist
ja und unsere Ukraine Korrespondentin
Katrin Eigendorf ist bei uns Katrin
bachmuth warum kämpft wird da so hart
darum gekämpft was was ist die tiefere
Bedeutung dieses Ortes wachmut hat schon
eine strategische Bedeutung auch das
Ziel werde mir Putins war es ja vor
allem im Osten der Ukraine über die
Region und dann jetzt Kontrolle zu
bekommen zunächst und wer bachmut
kontrolliert hat den direkten Zugang zu
der Region denn jetzt deswegen ist es
eigentlich ein wichtiger Punkt den Putin
erobern muss es geht dann weiter nach
einfach in die Stadt kremators die jetzt
im Prinzip sozusagen die Hauptstadt ist
seitdem Don jetzt besetzt ist also das
noch von Ukrainern kontrollierte Gebiet
es ist aber mittlerweile eigentlich muss
man sagen zu einer symbolischen Schlacht
auch geworden die weit über die
strategische hinausgeht wo sich beide
Seiten wirklich erbitterte Kämpfe
liefern es sind die schlimmsten Kämpfe
die so sagt man wie in diesem Krieg
bisher erlebt haben nein das ist dann
ein abnutzungskrieg bei dem die Ukraine
letztendlich darauf wartet dass es neue
Waffen und Munition aus dem Westen gibt
oder ja also wir sehen den bachmut ganz
klar dass alle Voraussagen von
Militärstrategen nicht eingetroffen sind
die Ukraine ist dort deutlich unterlegen
und was ich höre was ich auch jetzt im
im Osten der Ukraine bei Gesprächen mit
Militärs gehört haben
man wird wahrscheinlich über kurz oder
lang bachmut aufgeben müssen weil dort
so viele Soldaten sterben dass das
einfach für die Ukraine nicht mehr
haltbar ist
seit den ersten Tricks Wochen in der
Ukraine kreuz und quer durch das
landgerei ist jetzt gerade aus Racke
wiedergekommen und jetzt ein Blick
darauf wirfst auf diesen Jahrestag wo
steht die Ukraine im Moment in diesem
Krieg
ich würde sagen das Land steht an einem
Tiefpunkt obwohl
natürlich Präsident selenski den Blick
darauf richtet dass das Land zusammen
steht dass der Westen hinter dem Land
steht
ist es einfach ein bitterer Tag für
dieses Land alle Menschen haben im
Prinzip in irgendeiner Form Opfer für
diesen Krieg gebracht viele Menschen
sind gestorben und was die Ukraine heute
sehen und wissen ist dieser Krieg wird
weitergehen der endet ja nicht heute ist
sondern das was sie im vergangenen Jahr
erlebt haben dieser ganze Schrecken der
ist noch lange nicht zu Ende und im
Prinzip hat keiner eine klare
Perspektive wann dieser Krieg zu
gewinnen ist und die Ukraine Wissen auf
dem Verhandlungsweg ist der kurzfristig
nicht zu beenden sondern nur mit
weiteren schweren Opfern mit weiterer
Unterstützung des Westens danke dir
Katrin
neben Deutschland und Polen haben heute
auch die Schweden und Kanada weitere
Lieferungen von Leopard 2 Panzern
angekündigt damit käme insgesamt wohl
doch noch ein ganzes Bataillon dieser
modernen Kampfpanzer zu sammeln und
halten in Deutschland ja nicht alle
Waffenlieferungen für den richtigen Weg
doch eine Mehrheit der Bevölkerung
unterstützt die Hilfe für die Ukraine
auch militärische über die vielen
Kundgebungen die es heute zum Jahrestag
in Deutschland gab berichtet Christian
von Rechenberg
Deutschland ist Blau-Gelb am Jahrestag
der Katastrophe sind Tausende auf den
Beinen auch in Berlin wo sie der
regierenden Bürgermeisterin lauschen und
dem ukrainischen Botschafter wo sie
seinem Land versichern wir stehen an
eurer Seite
haben sie Sorge um den Frieden ja habe
ich
große Sorge aber es hilft nichts wenn
man sich jetzt unterwirft dann wird es
noch schlimmer für die Ukraine auf jeden
Fall
Friedensgebet in München nicht nur
Kardinal Marx ist gekommen alle
Konfessionen sind eingeladen zu diesem
stimmungsvollen Moment in St Michael
zusammen sein die Gemeinschaft
bekräftigen viele Gründe führen die
Menschen heute hierher
ein Jahr das reist einem einfach aus dem
Sessel raus dann bleibt man nicht zu
Hause auch nicht bei Regen sondern
versucht man irgendwo einen Kontakt dass
man sein Zeichen setzen kann und was
Kontakt und Zeichen angeht ist diese
Kundgebung unübertroffen heute sie
beginnt in Osnabrück und endet in
Münster die friedenskette ist 50 km lang
für eine Kirchengemeinden und Parteien
hatten aufgerufen knapp 20.000 hätten
sich angemeldet an den Hand solidarisch
mit der Ukraine
nicht aber mit der eigenen Regierung
nicht hier am Dresdner Elbufer wo AFD
und pegida den Jahrestag auf ihre Art
begehen nach ihrer Lesart der
westentrüge Mitschuld am Krieg Russland
verteidige sich nur vor der Frauenkirche
demonstriert zuvor ein bürgerliches
Bündnis den anderen Ton Dresdens
Stille 12 Uhr Hamburg hält inne eine
Minute lang sind die Gedanken bei den
Opfern des Krieges vor allem bei den
Kindern wer mag kann vom Rathaus
Spielsachen Spenden der Erinnerung einen
kurzen Moment schenken
vor einem Jahr ich weiß genau was ich
gemacht habe an dem Donnerstag als ihr
aufgestanden bin und das gehört habe wie
schlimm das da war und wie normal in
Anführungsstrichen das inzwischen ist
und das hat mich so ein bisschen ja
schockiert hat auch diese
Kunstinstallation heute in Berlin ein
russischer T-72 abgeschossen vor Kiew
abgestellt vor der russischen Botschaft
auch ein Zeichen das mag irritieren es
mag provozieren es soll heißen hört auf
zu schießen ehrlich gesagt habe ich
zuerst gedacht das ist eine Schnapsidee
aber wenn ich jetzt so davor stehe muss
ich sagen das ist ein ganz starkes
Symbol also
berührt mich am Abend dann gleicher
Stelle so etwas wie panzerparty sie
feiern ihre Solidarität und irgendwie
auch den Sieg des Guten über das Böse
ihren sehnlichsten Wunsch
viele Hintergründe zu diesem Krieg zu
dem was aktuell geschieht und dem was in
den letzten 365 Tagen geschehen ist
finden Sie bei uns natürlich auch online
Dokumentationen Reportagen Analysen und
aktuelle Meldungen
die USA haben heute weitere Sanktionen
gegen Russland verkündet damit beginnt
jetzt Hanna Zimmermann die Nachrichten
in Mainz
guten Abend auch von meiner Seite mit
einem neuen Sanktionspaket gegen
Russland wollen die USA die dortige
Wirtschaft weiter schwächen und damit
die Finanzierung des kriegserschweren
die Maßnahmen richten sich gegen mehr
als 200 Einzelpersonen sowie russische
Banken und Unternehmen Ziel sei dabei
auch die Metall- und Bergbaubranche
erklärte das US-Finanzministerium
und auch die EU-Staaten haben sich am
Abend auf ein weiteres Paket mit
Sanktionen gegen Russland verständigt
die neuen Strafmaßnahmen sehen unter
anderem zusätzliche
Handelsbeschränkungen vor
der chemikonzern BASF hat angekündigt
2600 Stellen zu streichen fast zwei
Drittel davon in Deutschland allein im
Stammwerk Ludwigshafen sollen etwa 700
Arbeitsplätze in der Produktion
wegfallen und mehrere Anlagen
geschlossen werden die Beschäftigten
will der Konzern aber Jobs in anderen
Betrieben anbieten Hintergrund der
Stellenstreichungen seien unter anderem
die stark gestiegenen Energiekosten
erklärte der DAX-Konzern
im Tarifstreit des öffentlichen Dienstes
haben die Gewerkschaften neue
Warnstreiks angekündigt nachdem die
zweite Verhandlungsrunde mit Bund und
Kommunen gestern keine Einigung brachte
am Montag soll unter anderem an den
Flughäfen Köln-Bonn und Düsseldorf
gestreikt werden die Arbeitgeber hatten
gestern unter anderem ein Lohnplus von
5% angeboten die Gewerkschaften fordern
dagegen 10,5% mehr
Pflegebedürftige sollen stärker
entlastet werden dafür sollen
Versicherte zukünftig höhere Beiträge
zahlen nach einem Entwurf des
Gesundheitsministeriums könnte der
Beitragssatz zum ersten Juli von bisher
3,05 Prozent auf 3,4 Prozent des
Bruttolohns steigen für Kinderlose sogar
insgesamt auf vier Prozent für Familien
soll es dagegen ab dem zweiten Kind
Entlastungen geben
und wir melden uns noch mal aus Kiew von
diesem Jahrestag eine Woche waren meine
Kollegen und ich hier und wir werden die
Menschen denen wir hier begegnet sind
nicht vergessen an einige wollen wir
jetzt zum Abschied noch mal erinnern
[Musik]
für alle Bewohner dieser Stadt dass die
Nacht weiter ruhig bleibt auch wenn das
natürlich kein Zeichen dafür wäre dass
ich der Krieg abschwächt er wird noch
weitergehen und die Ukraine wird weiter
um ihre Existenz kämpfen mit einem
Willen der sehr eindrücklich ist damit
sind wir am Ende unserer Sendung gegen
0.30 meldet sich von hier noch mal
schließe mit dem heute journal Update
und ich sage auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten Abend der Winter
klopft jetzt am Wochenende noch mal an
auf der kalten Seite dieses Tiefs hier
gehen jetzt kräftige Schauer mehr und
mehr in Schnee über heute Nacht ist das
vor allem im Norden und der Mitte bis in
tiefe Lagen der Fall im Erzgebirge
gibt's mit diesem strammen Nord Nordwest
wird auch Schneeverwehungen am meisten
fällt heute Nacht aber an den Alpen mit
um 10 cm Neuschnee oberhalb von 600
Metern dazu singen die Temperaturen auf
4 bis -2 Grad morgen gibt's eins bis
sechs am Rhein 78 Grad im Westen und im
Norden ist morgen auch am ehesten mal
die Sonne drinnen ansonsten wechselhaft
schneer Regen Schnee und Graupelschauer
Richtung Osten auch mal länger
anhaltender Schnee und vor allem im
Nordstau oder östlichen Mittelgebirge
der Winter ist einem Erzgebirge an den
Alpen sind noch mal um 10 cm möglich und
danach beruhigt sich das Wetter etwas es
kommt mehr und mehr die Sonne raus und
die Nächte werden knackig kalt tschüss
Musik Stars unvergleichliche Momente bei
mir für euch